radical and repugnant Republican
congresswoman Lauren bobert recently
seemingly bragged that she barely
learned what the three branches of
government were sort of bragging about
the fact that for her it's about
biblical citizenship which is quite a
term I barely learned what the three
branches of government were and now our
children
are being taught to hate their fellow
classmates because of their gender the
color of their skin
the most disturbing aspect of this isn't
only that the folks who claim to be
about the Constitution brag about
opposing separation of church and state
they want civil government dictated by
not just a church but a Christian Church
it's that the pseudo-intellectualism and
the anti-intellectualism has actually
become a badge of honor for a lot of
these people